[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نقدم خلال ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه اليوم
خمس الايرانيين فقط يدعمون بقاء النظام
10 شركات عالميه ومحليه تنضم لبيئه
التقنيات الناشئه في السعوديه منها
مايكروسوفت
الداخليه السعوديه تكشف للعربيه الخدمات
الالكترونيه لمنصه ابشر توفر 17 مليار
ريال سنويا
الرابعه ايضا
منظمه السياحه العالميه تختار العلا
للاحتفال بافضل القرى السياحيه خلال العام
البدايه من ايران حيث يعيش النظام مرحله
شكل غير مسبوقه الاحتجاجات ولا تتوقف
واعزله الدوله عن المجتمع الدوليه
يعتمد عليه نظام وطهران لضمان البكر تقرير
لصحيفه
عن اعتماد السلطات على الاف المؤيدين
المخلصين لوقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
المستمره منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
وافادت صحيفه الامريكيه بان الاف المخلصين
الذين تستخدمهم الحكومه الحرس الثوري
والميليشيات الاخرى الاقل رسميا مؤكده بعد
استطلاعات الراي التي اجرتها مؤسسات غير
ربحيه مقرها هولندا انا واحدا من اصل خمسه
ايرانيين يدعمون النظام اشاره تقرير ايضا
الى ان هذه النواه الصلبه غالبا ما يكون
اعضائها من خلفيات متواضعه اقتصاديا
ومحافظه اجتماعيا لكن النظام يضمن ولائهم
عبر من
ووظائف واسلحه يقدمها لهم للحفاظ على
الوضع الراهن وفقا لويل ستينجر
[تصفيق]
ومتابعه للاحتجاجات حضر المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص لشؤون ايران روبرتماليه على تويتر
من ان عشرات الايرانيين معرضون لخطر
الاعدام لمشاركتهم في الاحتجاجات واضاف
المسؤول الامريكيه بان الكثير من المحتجين
يقولون انهم تعرضوا للتعذيب لانتزاع
اعترافتهم وتم اتهامهم بارتكاب جرائم
تتعلق بالامن القومي في محاكمه ثوريه لا
تسمح لهم باختيار محامي وفق قول روبرت
مالك
طلب وزير الخارجيه الى ايطاليا انطونيو
تجانيه سلطات الايرانيه بفتح حوار مع
المحتجين ياتي هذا الطلب الايطالي يعاقب
استدعاء السفير في روما للاحتجاج على
القمع غير المقبول للتظاهرات التي تقودها
النساء في ايران بحسب ما اعلنه مكتب
الخارجيه الايطاليه وسبق اندان الوزير
ترجاني الوضع في ايران ووصفه بالعار وغير
المقبول وقال ان روما كتبنا نهجا صارما في
الدفاع عن المراه
ايضا في الملف النوويه
في البرلماني
لا تنوي تراجع عن مطاردها في المفاوضات
وشدد ابو الفضل عمه
خطه العمل الشامله المشترك يمكن تحقيقه من
جانبهرون لكن النتيجه تعتمد على واقعيه
الجانب الاخر واضاف بان تفسيرات
الاوروبيين للتطورات الداخليه الايرانيه
غير دقيقه وتروج لسوره خاطئه بان طهران
مستعده لتقديم تنازلات
وبالنسبه الى اسرائيل قال مسؤولون امنيون
ان التحولات مرتبه على ساحه الدوليه ستؤدي
الى استئناف المحادثات النوويه بين ايران
والقوه الكبرى وفقا لصحيفه ارتس واضاف
المصدر ان التقديرات الامنيه الاسرائيليه
تشير الى ان الولايات المتحده معنيه
بالتوقيع على اتفاق النووي مع ايران رغم
تصريحات بيض الاخيره بان الاتفاق النوويه
مات وقال مسؤولون اسرائيليون ان التصريحات
زله لسان وليس ملزما
بروكسيل تنضمي لنا الباحثه في الشان
الايراني ممثل قوي سيد منى اهلا وسهلا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه
حول العوامل التي يعتمد عليها النظام في
بقائه متماسكا امام هذه الاحتجاجات هل
تتفقين اولا مع ما جاء في هذا التقرير
مره اخرى يعني طريقه اللي كتب العنوان
ممكن لو كان كتب بطريقه عكسيه اللي وصل
المفهوم مختلف تماما يعني بدال ما نكتب
واحد على خمسه يدعمونا النظام من افضل كان
يقول ان الثمانين بالمائه من الشعب
الايراني لا يدعم هذا النظام يعني
الغالبيه العظمى ولكن على ما يبدو حتى
الان ما زال الاعلام الغربي يتغزل
بالملالي حتى في طريقه كتابتهم للعنوان
للعناوين يخطئون بهذه الطريقه او يحاولون
يعني يبينون نسخه حتى ولو يعني يقولون
فيها ان النظام في ازمه يعني بالعناوين
يحرفون الحقائق بالنسبه لالي هكذا يعني
همم يعني هناك دائما
اقاليموهات كان بسوريا شبيحه حرقوا البلاد
وفي ليبيا كانت تحاله اذا ما اخطاء يعني
هذه الاقليات دائما موجوده
مستعده ان تعمل المستحيل همم اما اما
ايدولوجيا بالفعل همم
مرتبطين لهذه الافضل ما هو مستعدين يعملون
المستحيل يعني همم بنظام الايراني كما
باقي الافضل من الديكتاتوريه لديها قوات
البسيج في من هم بالفعل ايدولوجين يظنون
المحتاجين الان بسبب رفع شعاراتهم اللي
تتعارض مع ايدولوجيه النظام ان هم مثلا
مرتين او كفره
بالفعل استخدم هذا النظام هذه السياق
بالفعل بالتعامل مع المحتاجين ان هم
مجموعه من المرتدين على الدين همم اخلاق
كثير من ال- همم همم
بانهم يهاجمون المحجبات او يحرقون الجوامع
في حال لم يحصل هذا تم الهجوم على مندوبيه
في المدن المختلفه ولكن لم يتم حقق تمامه
لذلك يعني ما زال لديهم بعض من الحاضر
الشعبيه عند هذه الفئه ولو كانت صغيره
يعني احنا شاهدنا همم كثير من المحجبات
حتى في صوره جميله جدا ام محجبه جاءت
وصحبه ابنها اللي هو من قوات الام وقعدته
على البيت لانه لا اريدك ان تهاجم
المحتجين مجموعه اخرى نعم فقراء مع الاسف
موجوده هذا الامر ويعملونك مرتزقه للنظام
الايراني هذا الامر موجود ولكن هل اخليه
يحافظ على النظام بسوريا نعم مستمر بشار
الاسد ولكن الارض محروق اي بلد نحن نتكلم
هل ايران تستطيع ان تستمر ايران محروقه
ممكن ان تستمر الان احنا وصلنا يعني ارقام
قياسيه سعر الدولار في اسواق الايراني
هجوم الايرانيين لا يسحبوا اموالهم من
المصارف هجوم الارهاين لشراء الذهب
والدولار في اسواق كلها سببت ازمه
اقتصاديه يعني حتى هؤلاء المرتزقه هنا
الاموال في خلال سنه القادم
يمكن يعني همم ان تكون سببت ربما في في
بقاء هذا النظام متماسك الغير ما ذكر يعني
على مستوى الباسيج والحرس الثوري الايراني
يتحدث عن عوامل الخارجيه يعني في موقف
وضربما في الخارج في موقف المجتمع الدولي
ايضا الى اي حد وصل في تعاطي مع هذه
الاحتجاجات ومع النظام الايراني
اوروبا ثاني ايران تستخدم قضيه ملف
المخدرات نعرفهم متورطين في ملف المخدرات
دائما تهدد اوروبا بملف المخدرات لانه
تحاول اوروبا الى صاحب حرب بين تجار
المخدرات وانها تدعي انها بوابه امام
افغانستان حتى احد حدوش انا لديها ارقام
اعدامات عاليه انهم تجار مخدرات هذا من
طرفيته تهدد اوروبا ايضا في ملفات الارهاق
كثير من القضايا الارهابيه حصلت في اوروبا
من قتل المعارضه او انفجارات عملوها في
اوروبا همم ايضا تهدد اوروبا في قضيه
المهاجرين لانها تحتضن ثلاثه مليون
تهدد ان تكون بتردهم وهم ياتون الى اوروبا
وتعمل ازمه ثانيه لاربعه يعني اوروبا ايضا
لديها مشاعر مع ايران لا يعني تتنازل بسبب
هذه القضايا ولكن بعد التدخل الايراني في
اوكرانيا والحرب يعني ايران فتحت حرب
عليها مباشره ما ما دول الاوروبيه لذلك
نراهم الان ممكن نغير مواقفه ولكن فيما
سبق
سياساتهم سياسه احتوائيه كما انه عدد سكان
ايران 80 مليون عدد كبير منهم عايشين في
دول الاجنبيه لا ايضا اوروبا تتخوف في حال
كان هناك عدم الاستقرار كل هؤلاء ممكن
ياتون الى الدول الغربيه ايضا يتخوفون
منهج موجه هجره ايرانيين نحن لدينا عدد
كبير من جاري يعني شفنا كيف هذه الجاليه
اذا اثرت على السياسيين وكيف عمل الضغط
حتى يدعمون هذه الاحتجاجات اما بالنسبه
لعوامل داخليه هي بالفعل استمرت بالقمع
والثاني سبب ايران بلد غني جدا ثروات
كثيره اللي موجوده في ايران حتى الان
استطاعت نوع يعني
احتجاجات يعني نحن امام بدايه جديده هل
يمكن ان تستمر بنفس الزخم في نفس الاطار
هل يمكن ان تتوسع في طريقه مواجهتها لنظام
بشكل همم او باخر برايك
انا احتجاجات كيف حاله ثوريه واحتجاجات
ليست مطلبيه هي احتجاجات الاسقاط النظام
احتجاجات بالفعل بينت هناك شرخ واضح بين
النظام
الايديولوجي وبين الشعب ومطالبات الشعب
لذلك يعني حتى ونقول انه استطاع ان يقمع
هذه المظاهرات بالقتل سوف يخرج لسبب اخر
اما اقتصادي او مره اخرى لقضايا اخرى يعني
هل ايران تتخلص من شرطه الاخلاق
هل سيكون بيتغير بالنظام شيء بشكل حتى
الشعب يتراجع لا لانه نحن لانتخابات كانت
مهندس يعني هندسه الانتخابات
الليله شعبيه كثيره بالنسبه يعني بالنسبه
للصوره هي همم ليست همم يعني حاله في وقت
معين انها عمليه التطور يعني قد يكون
لديها الصعود والنزول ولكن ما بقى ليه
ستستمر ممكن النمو بنفسه ضخم ولكن ممكن
بطرق اخرى منزلاوي
في رابع بعد قليل
بعد التلاعب بانظمه سوق الماليه السعوديه
الزام مواطن باعاده 55 مليون
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه اعلنت هيئه
الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه عن انضمام 10
شركات عالميه ومحليه للبيئه التنظيميه
التجريبيه
للتقنيات الناشئه وذلك بهدفه خلقه بيئه
مرنه ومحف ذلك الخدمات والحلول والمنتجات
المبنيه على التقنيات الناشئه وللمساهمه
ايضا في جذب الاستثمارات العالميه
والتعزيزه لاستثمارات المحليه عبر ابتكاري
بحلول وخدمات في بيئه تجريبيه ذات تنظيمات
مرنه
[موسيقى]
الضميري نفسك من الرياض مستشار تقنيه
المعلومات في هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء
والتقنيه الدكتور عبد العزيز البدري حياك
الله دكتور اهلا وسهلا فيك معنا
انضمام هذه العشرات العشر الشركات
السعوديه
لدى المنظم القطاع وايضا في نفس الوقت رفع
همم
الابتكاري والتقني لدى الشركات الواعده
والعقول المبتكره همم
منذ اطلاق او الاعلان عن البيئه تنظيميه
تجريبي البيئه التنظيميه تجريبيه لتقنيه
الناشئه
تقدموا عدد من الشركات همم فوق التوقعات
وقبلنا 10 همم بنسبه قبول 21% تقريبا همم
يعملون في مختلف همم الصناعات في قطاع
الطاقه في قطاع الصحه والاتصالات وايضا
الصناعه همم مجمل العشر شركات همم عندهم
همم
يعني براعه تقنيه في مجالات تقنيه محدده
مثلا الاشياء البلوكشن الحواس بالسحابيه
همم الذكاء الاصطناعي واخيرا تقنيات
الواقع المعزز والافتراضيه مش اهم الشركات
هذه طبعا ولله الحمد والمنه همم
واللي جاذبيه السوق همم في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والوجود العقول النيره
تقدمت للبيئه عده شركات محليه واجنبيه من
ابرازها مايكروسوفت سيمز همم وغيرها من
الشركات اللي همم فعلا اثبتت اهميه وجود
هذه الاداه التنظيميه لدى المنظم القطاعيه
ليش تهتم هذه الشركات اليوم بالسوق
السعودي او بالتنظيميه
كبير للشركات
موجوده ما كان في شيء سابقا لكن احنا
اليوم نعيش ثوره همم يعني في النضج
التنظيمي هائله جدا وايضا جاذبيه السوق
اصبحت اكثر شهيه لدى
المستثمرين سواء المحليين او الاجانب همم
[موسيقى]
بيئه تنظيميه التجريبيه هي احد همم
الادوات لجذب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه همم
لانه عندنا همم يعني عندنا الايدي الماهره
عندنا العقول النيره وعندنا نضج التنظيمي
القطاعي في مختلف القطاعات الذي يساهم في
همم يعني رفع من جاذبيه السوق بالاضافه
الى رؤيه السعوديه 2030 التي اوضحت ووضعت
نور ستار او ال- يعني النجم الشمال
للمملكه في هذا الاجانب طيب ما الذي يتغير
يعني بعد انضمامها هذه همم الشركات عملها
في مجال همم يعني
بالتنظيميه والتجريبيه في المملكه شيء
الكثير طبعا احنا نتكلم عن اول قطره همم
القادم اجمل واكبر هناك ان اعتقد شقين همم
لهذا السؤال في الفوائد قريبه المدى وفي
الفوائد بعيده المدى قريبه المدى نضج
التنظيمي لدى هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء
والتقنيه
معرفه الادوات التنظيميه المناسبه لكل
تقنيه ولكل همم يعني حاله استخدام همم
عندنا احنا مفهوم نؤمن فيه في هيئه
الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه الابتكار ثم
التنظيم احنا نعرف عالميه انا يعني العالم
يعرف انه التنظيم
فهو يقتل السوق قبل ما يبدا فاحنا العكس
احنا نروح للشركات نشجعهم نقول لهم احنا
نقعد نتعلم معكم نبغى نعرف كيف ننظم وبنفس
الوقت كيف يمكن ونحفز ونجذب الاستثمارات
لكم انتم همم يعني على سبيل المثال همم
حجم
ده الاموال او ال- ال- همم الاستثمارات
التي وصلت وجمعت من الشركات الناشئه كنا
نتوقع انها يصل الى واحد مليار ريال في
هذه السنه في النصف الاول تجاوز 2. همم
مليار ريال ريال همم وهذا اكثر من يعني
الرقم المتوقع جدا همم يعني هذا هو النضج
التنظيمي نحنا نطمح له اما فوائد يعني
المدى البعيد فنطنح باذن الله همم خلق
وظائف نوعيه همم يعني عديده بالاضافه الى
اسهامات همم ايجابيه في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي برده مش اهم هذه الوظائف
اليوم همم طبعا احنا نتكلم على نوعين من
الوظائف في وظائف تقنيه بحته لها نيش معين
لها طابع تقني همم اخطاء مختص همم في مجال
معين مثل الكلاط كمبيوتر من النادر انك
تحصل احد مختص في الكلاود بيحدثه او في
تقنيات الكلاغط كمبيوتر ونفس الكلام ينطبق
على الانترنت الاشياء والبلوكين والذكاء
الاصطناعي اليوم نشهد نموذج عالمي همم
يعني من نماذج الدكاله الصناعيه
نتعامل معها اليوم همم وصلت بقدرتين
القدره الحاسوبيه والقدره البشريه وهذا ما
نطنحلها باذن الله في هذا الوطن الشركات
ممكن تستفيد يعني
ما تحدثنا عن تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الامور يعني التقنيه اللي تذكرتها يعني
وهل ممكن نلحظ تغير في طبيعه عملها طبيعه
الابتكارات المقدمه في خاصه بتقنيه اليوم
يعني اصبحت تساهم في الكثير من الصناعات
الكثير من شئون الحياه المختلفه يعني طبعا
بلا شك التقنيه هي حجر الزاويه همم لنمو
جميع القطاعات نتكلم عن الصناعه الصحه
الاتصالات وغيرها من القطاعات همم الممكنه
الاساسي هي التقنيه همم
باذن الله سنشهد من خلال هذه البيئه همم
يعني همم يعني اضافات نوعيه لم نكن نشهدها
من قبل لان البيئه تمنح مساحه امنه همم
معفيه من بعض التنظيمات وبوجود بعض
الحوافز لعمل الابتكارات والتاكد من هذا
النموذج هو قابل
او مناسب ومنائم للسوق والشريحه المستهدفه
واحنا يعني نطرح باذن الله من هذه الدنيا
ان نعجل من تماركته وبما يسمى وقت الوصول
الى السوق من البذره الفكره حتى وجود
المنتج العميل
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يبارك فيك دكتور
في مستشفى المعلومات فيها هيئه الاتصالات
والفضاء
اعلنت النيابه العامه السعوديه عن الزامها
لمواطن باعاده 55 مليون ريال للقيام
بانشطه مخالفه لممارسات السوق الماليه
واكدت النيابه قيام المواطن بادخال اوامر
شراء بهدف التاثير في سعر السهم
وكذلك اوامر شراء بهدف تحقيق سعر مزاد
اغلاق مرتفع وتكرار العمليه 43 مره
مع غرامه ماليه قدرها مليونير وحرماني من
التداول على اسهم الشركات المدرجه في
السوق السوداء
كشفت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه العربيه عن
توفير منصه ابشر لسبعه عشر مليار ريال
سنويا من خلال الاستغناء عن الخدمات
الحكوميه التقليديه وفق للمتحدث باسمي
منصه ابشر طارق الحربي وكانت وزاره
الداخليه السعوديه اعلنت عن تدشين منصه
ابشر الالكترونيه ل 10 خدمات جديده من
اهمها خدمه الابلاغ عن سرقه السيارات
وتجديد الجواز السعودي واستعراض الهويه
رقميا لاضافه الى خدمه التحقق من امكانيه
الخروج عبر المنافذ البريه
السنه هذه في ملتقى ابشر 22 تم اطلاقا
مجموعه من الخدمات الجديده من مختلفه
القطاعات من اهمها خدمات الهويه الرقميه
بشكلها الجديد ايضا خدمه التحقق من هذا
الهويه الرقميه مقدمه الى القطاع الخاص
والجهات الحكوميه كذلك لدينا خدمه ابشر
سفر وهي مقدمه للراقبين
بالخروج من المنافذ البريه
وكذلك لدينا او تم اطلاق خدمات الابلاغ عن
المركبات المسروقه تقدمها المديريه العامه
للامن العام وخدمات الجواز السعودي
الاصدار والتجديد للجواز الجديده والجواز
الالكترونيه اللي تقدمه المديريه العامه
للجوازات الحقيقه وسط اقتصادي فقط ابشر
الاكثر من 17 مليار ريال سنويا كافر على
الاقتصاد السعودي سواء على مقدم الخدمه او
على المستفيد من الخدمه او على الاقتصاد
والبنيه التحتيه بشكل عام
فالحقيقه لدينا مجموعه من الاحصائيات
الرائعه نتكلم سنويا عندنا مليونين همم
خدمه همم او مليون العمليه شهريا همم تنفذ
اجرائيه همم تم تقديم اكثر من 380 خدمه
عبر المنصه همم عدد العملاء يقترب من 27
مليون هويه رقميه طبعا هؤلاء العملاء
يستخدمون الرصافه ابشر ويستخدمون ايضا
المنصات الاخرى عبرى النفاذ الوطني الموحد
معنا من الرياض المتحدث باسم منصه ابشر
طارق بن حميد همم طارق حياك الله معك في
نشره الرابعه انا ودي بس توضح لنا اكثر 17
مليار ريال مبلغ كبير جدا يعني كيف تمكنك
منصه ابشر من توفير هذا المبلغ
الاشتراك في البدايه طبعا الدراسه اللي
تمت همم على منصه ابشر الحقيقه من ناحيه
المؤخره الاقتصادي هي طبعا من عده جوانب
الاقتصادي الجانب الامني
كده يعني لكن احنا نبغى نركز على الجامع
الاقتصادي همم الوفره على ثلاث جهات او
ثلاث اطراف المستطيل اللي هو مقدم همم
[موسيقى]
خاصه همم الطرف الاخر اللي هو مقدم الخدمه
للقطاعات وزاره الداخليه
والطرف الثالث اللي هو الاقتصاد البنيه
التحتيه كل ما يتعلق
في الامور انه ولا في الادوات التي يمكن
استخدامها وفي المتاحه للجميع فتم تم
احتساب الوفر من كل زاويه باختلاف طبعا
همم
المعادلات التي يعني اللي تم افتراره ايضا
الاحترابات وخرجنا بهذا المبلغ اللي نجد
ايضا انه الى حد كبير يعتبر متحفظ قد يكون
الاثر اقتصادها يعني المبلغ الحقيقي ممكن
يكون اكثر من كذب
يعني لما نقول احنا
كبار وتم اخذ المعادلات في الاعتبار هذا
الذي نعرفه ان احنا متاكدين منه مثلا سعر
تقديم الخدمه او تكلفه الترقيم الخدمه
التقليديين عبر المكات هذا يمكن حسابه بكل
بساطه باحتساب التكاليف مقابل المقبله لكن
في امور اخرى قد تكون يعني من الصعب همم
رقميه فبالتالي نعتقد انه بدون اخذ هذه
المعايير او هذه الاعتبارات همم في عين ال
ال في هذه المعادلات اللي تم اييي يعني
نقول
خلقها ااه نعتقد انه المبلغ قد يكون اكبر
من ذلك صحيح اليوم كمان المنصه عالنتجين
خدمات جديده او عشر خدمات جديده لفت نظري
موضوع الابلاغ عن سرقه السيارات لكن اكثر
المشاكل اللي كان متواجه السعوديه انه
يتجه الى مقر الشرطه همم وبعد كده يعني
المواطن نفسه هو اللي يروح يبحث عن سيارته
يعني في في في كثير من الاحوال ايش اللي
بيتغير بعد تقديم الشخصي او يبلغ عن سرقه
سيارته من خلال منصه همم
الخدمه المقدمه عن طريق ابشر هي فقط فيما
يتعلق
بمعنى سابقا كان من المفروض الشخص اللي
همم يعني تعرضت للسرقه اوحتها لوحه
المركبه السابقه
يجب ان يتوجه لم زي الشرط الان يستطيع انه
يرفع البلاغ عن طريق منصه ابشر وست ستقوم
همم يعني الجهات المختصه في المديريه
العامه للامن العام لمعالجه هذا البلاء
وايضا يمكن للمستفيد يعني الرجوع الى
المناصه الى حسابه في ابشر ويتحقق من
التحديثات هذا باختصار الخدمه المقدمه عن
طريق منصه تاثير حاليا اهم الخدمات
الجديده ايضا وهل هناك نيه للتوسع فيها
وسؤال اخر من زاويه اخرى انت تعرف انه
يعني موضوع ابشر كان مثيل للجدل خاصه في
نظره الخارج لهذه همم من الصوت واتهامات
بانه هذا يستخدم للتجسس على الناس وغيرها
من الامور كيف يعني تدافعون على هذه
المنصه او تردون على مثل هذه العقاب
طبعا نتكلم عن الجزريات الخدمات الخدمات
الجديده التي اطلقت باختصار خدمات الهويه
الرقميه بشكلها الجديد كذلك خدمات تتيح
للجهات التحقق من هذه الهويه الرقميه
وتحكم من موسيقيتها كذلك فيما يتعلق ايضا
بالهويه الرقميه تهنا للمقيمين همم
الاطلاعه واستعراق وثائق الرقميه للتابعين
همم لهم همم خدمه البلاغ عن همم المركبات
المسروقه ايضا خدمه او ما وصلنا الى مرحله
في تجديد واسرار الجواز الالكتروني بشكل
كامل اللي هو الجواز الجديد المقدم مدير
العمل الجوازات ايضا خدمه همم
المدفوعات الحكوميه والرسوم الحكوميه
لخدمات الداخليه عبر همم فيما يتعلق طبعا
ايش المستقبل
لوزاره الداخليه في مشوارها وفي مشروع همم
الاتهامات السابقه التي وصلت فيها المنصه
طبعا الموضوع هذا مخفي فيه وكانت يعني
مبني على موضوع التعقب اوضحنا سابقا يعني
في وقتها للاعلام ووضحنا ايضا بالشركات
المقدمه لمتاجر التطبيقات انه تطبيق ابشر
لا يستخدم
يعني خاصيه التتبع اساسا وفي النهايه هي
فقط ابشر هي منصه لتقديم يعني يعني الخدمه
تقدم يدويا في المكاتب الان اصبحت تقدم
للمستفيد في مكانه لا اكثر ولا اقل وطبعا
كانت يعني كل الادعاءات في وقتنا كانت غير
صحيحه وتم الرد عليها
[موسيقى]
الكثير من الناس في حياتهم اليوميه يعني
الحمد لله
رابعه ايضا بعد قليل حضور خجول للسينما
العمانيه والرابعه توثيق عقبات صناعه
الافلام في السلط
الايرانيين فقط يدعمون بقاء النظام
لبيئه التقنيات السعوديه الناشئه منها
مايكروسوفت
داخليه السعوديه تكشف للعربيه الخدمات
الالكترونيه لمنصه ابشر 2017 مليار ريال
سعودي
منظمه السياحه العالميه تختار العلا
لاحتفال بافضل القرى السياحيه خلال العام
اهلا بكم تسجل محافظه طريف السعوديه ادنى
درجات الحراره اليوم بواقع الدرجتين
مئويتين وفقا لتوقعات المركز السعودي
للارصاد بما ستكون درجات الحراره في
القريات والدوادمي عند اربع درجات مئويه
وفي جنوب السعوديه تشير وتوقعات الى تسجيل
مدينه ابها سبع درجات
من ابها ينتظر الى مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم حياك الله يا اسامه كيف في الدرجه
او كيف الحراره والاجواء الان في ابها
لجميع مشاهدين قناه العربيه بالتاكد اليوم
مناطق جنوب السعوديه بشكل عام وعسير بشكل
خاص درجه الحراره فيها منخفضه جدا وتسجلت
اليوم درجه الحراره في ابها في سبعه درجه
مئويه صباحا مع انها تكون ايضا اكثر
انخفاضا بالمساء المركز الوطني للارصاد
ايضا اعلن ان هناك ايضا عدد من المناطق
جنوب السعوديه سوف تكون مطيره خلال الايام
القادمه جازان ثلاث ايام خطيره عيسى عسير
ايضا ثلاث ايام كانت مطيره جدا خلال يومين
هذه ايضا درجه الحراره تتفاوت ما بين
السابعه درجه مئويه الى 13 درجه مئويه
طبعا احنا حدث اليوم عن منطقه ابها كونها
اقل درجات الحراره الموجوده مسجل اليوم في
مناطق جنوب السعوديه ايضا بالتزامن مع
درجه الحراره المسجله ايضا في منطقه همم
الباحه الجدير بالذكر ان هذه الاجواء
بالنسبه لاهالي المناطق الجنوبيه جيده جدا
بمعنى انه اهالي المناطق الساحليه او
التهاميه يصعدون الى الجبال لقضاء ال- ال-
الاجازه الصيفيه او لقضاء ايضا همم بعض
الاوقات الممتعه بالنسبه لهم ايضا
ايضا اهالي المناطق الجبليه
وهل بها ينزلون يعني اليوم احنا امس واحنا
طالعين من العقبه اهالي ابها نازلين جيزان
اهالي جيزان طالعين نافا هذا ما يعني
الاجواء ايضا عندما تكون متفاوته يكون
هناك حركه كبيره جدا على المستوى السياحي
اقف الان وبجانب هنا ايضا شارع الفن عدد
من المناطق السياحيه الكبرى جدا في ابها
التي تشهد حضور كبيرا جدا للزوار
والسائحين همم انا اتفاجا خالد ايضا انه
كنت تتوقع انه انا بس اللي فيني برد شويه
حتى الناس برده يشعرون بانخفاض درجات
الحراره المركز الوطني اقدر اصعد اعلى انه
في الايام القادمه ستكون درجات الحراره
اقل همم انخفاض هناك في عسير والباحه هذه
هذه الدرجات الحراره المسجل الى
يومنا هذا متفاوت الصباح تكون من سبعه الى
عشره المساء تكون من سبعه او من خمسه الى
سبعه درجه مئويه تتفاوت ايضا عن يوم اخر
امس كانت درجه الحراره
في
المقاهي في غيرهم مناطق يعني المهمه فيها
ابها يعني
م
اييي لم تؤثر ايضا على مستوى الامطار لم
تسجل اي حالات مثلا لانزلاقات او اي اي
حوادث كانت الامطار طبيعيه جدا مع ان
الامطار ايضا كانت مسجله بكميات غزيره جدا
لكن على مستوى الحركه نفس الحركه لم تعلق
الدراسه لم يكن هناك اي يعني اي عائق في
الحركه بالنسبه لابها الناس تمشي بشكل
طبيعي جدا المقاهي المطاعم المناطق
السياحيه ايضا تشهد حضوره كبير جدا حتى في
اوقات الدوام فقس ايضا عليها في ايام
الاجازه بالتحديد شكرا لك من ابها مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم
تحديات عديده تواجه قطاع صناعه السينما في
سلطنه عمان في ظل غياب المعاهد وشركات
ريتاج والدعم الحكومي والاجتماعي لهذا
الخطاب عبد الرحمن العصيمي
[موسيقى]
تحديات عديدات صناعه السينما في سلطنه
عمان فبالرغم من وجود مهرجانات محليه
عديده الى ان حضور الفيلم العماني بحسب
النقاد لا يزال خجوله في المشهد السينمائي
الخليجي والعربي اخر هذه المهرجانات
مهرجان السينما المراه والطفل الدولي في
العاصمه مسقط الذي اتى بمشاركه 81% اختار
منها 41 فيلما من 14 دوله اول مهرجان
في السلطنه كونك مختص في هذا النوع من
الافلام حيث دمجنا ما بين سينما المراه
وسينما الطفل واصبح لنا اول مهرجان وهذا
المهرجان يعتبر اول مهرجان
يدمج المراه والطفل في العالم ليلى
الحمدون بدورها تعارض بشده ارى بعض النق
السينمائيين القائلين بغياب السينما
العماني هذا اتهام انا ارفضه
واعتبر بان هناك
المسك منكيشن مثل ما يسموه انه
الاخرين لا يبحثون ولا يدرون احنا عندنا
مهرجانات قائمه حول همم يعني مهرجان
الكبير في مسقط وعندنا في الفتره الاخيره
انتقلنا الى مهرجانات في المناطق من جهته
يؤكد رئيس الجمعيه العمانيه للسينما
والمسرح حميد العامري ان صناعه الافلام في
السلطنه لا تزالوا بحاجه الى مزيد من
الدعم الحكومي والاجتماعي
لنجاح همم
اكبر تهتم بهذا الاسلام طبعا هذه لها
ادوار كثير
للمخرجين حتى بعضهم دورات خارجيه همم
استقدام او يعني حضور بعض الكتاب دول
الخارجيه والمخرجين همم للتاهيل مبادراتهم
تخرجوا بين فتره واخرى في السلطنه لتشجيع
هذا القطاع اصنع في المكفي عمان مبادره
دشنتها الجمعيه العمانيه للسينما والمسرح
خلال مشاركتها في اكسبو 20 20 في دبي انا
ذاك بهدف تشجيع صناعه وانتاج الافلام
السينمائيه في البلاد مبادرات يعول عليها
البعض والبعض الاخر ينتظر المزيد عبد
الرحمن العصيمي من مسقط العرب تستعد
محافظه العلا شمال غرب السعوديه لاستضافه
حفل منظمه السياحه العالميه لتكريم اثنتين
وثلاثين قريه
من 18 دوله حول العالم ضمن افضل القرى
السياحه
2022 نهايه فبراير المقبل وضمت القائمه
البلده القديمه في العلا التي يعود
تاريخها الى سبعه قرون وتتكون اكثر من
اكثر من 900 مبنى تم ترشيده من الطوب
الطيني وعدد من القلاع المحيطه بها
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في العلا حيث ساهم دليل شتاء
السعوديه لهذا العام بالتسهيل اختيار
السياح
لوجاتهم في المملكه مهرجان شتاء طنطوره
احد هذه الاوجه
[موسيقى]
مهرجان شتاء طنطوره بدا لا احد يحتار الى
اين يذهب في العلا فعاليات ترفيهيه
وموسيقيه مواقع جديده بمطاعم ومقاهي فاخره
وبالطبع استكشاف الحضارات القديمه امر مهم
لجميع الزوار فهيا بنا في رحله عبر الزمن
في عاصمه الممالك القديمه
[موسيقى]
استنشاق الهواء النقي بين الجبال خلال
الاقامه في العربات المتنقله امر ممتع
وهذا ما يتيحه مهرجان شتاء طنطوره
[موسيقى]
البلده القديمه في العلا اذا زرت هذا
المكان فانت محظوظ لان منظمه السياحه
العالميه اختارت البلده القديمه في العلا
كواحده من افضل الوجهات السياحيه في
العالم لعام 2022 هنا مقاهي على الطراز
القديم ومحال تجاريه تقدم هدايا للاصدقاء
والاقارب
[موسيقى]
بعد زياره دادان ومدائن صالح وجبل الفيل
والمناطق التاريخيه الاخرى في العلا يمكن
هنا للسياح الاستمتاع بتجربه ليليه فريده
من خلال التعرف اكثر على الفنون الشعبيه
لدى السعوديين من العلا نواف عزيز العربيه
مر على جزيره العربيه عده عصور منها عصر
السفانا وعصر الامطار الموسميه وعصر
التصحر تفاصيل مع خالد الزعيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
برا على الجزيره العربيه عصفور
متناطحه عصر التجمد وعصر سافانا وعصر
الامطار الموسميه وعصر التصحر ففي العصور
المطيره تخلقت اعداد لا متناهيه من
الشغايه والشعاب والاوديه والتي كانت
انهار جاريه فوادي الرمه يصب بشط العرب
ووادي حنيفه يصب الخليج العربي وفي عصر
التصحر تحولت الى مجاريه خامده تنهضوا في
الحالات المطريه بعضها ينهض في كل سنه
وبعضها ينهض كل 11 سنه والبعض الاخر ينهض
كل 70 سنه تبعا لدوره المطر التقريبيه بين
المطر والارض عشق سواليف فاضت من اشواقه
وعيون
السحابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واغلب الاوديه تنتهي في بحار اوديه سلطنه
عمان واليمن ومرتفعات الحجاز ومرتفعات
عسير والبعض ينتهي في قاع محاط بالمرتفعات
من كل الجوانب واذا فاضل معنا سميت فيضه
فيضه نوره فيضه الخفس فيضه التنهات وفياض
الاحترام وكذلك فياض الحاره واذا نشف
الماء وتبخر عنه وطلع الربيع سميناه روضه
احبك حبا لو يفيض يسيره على الناس مات
الناس من شده الحب
[موسيقى]
العناوين
تكشف عن واقع صادم لنظام في ايران الخمس
الايرانيين فقط يدعمون بقاء النظام
[تصفيق]
لبيئه التقنيه الناشئه في السعوديه منها
مايكروسوفت
الداخليه السعوديه تكشف للعربيه الخدمات
الالكترونيه لمنصه بشير توفير 2017 مليار
ريال سنويا
منظمه السياحه العالميه تختار العلا
للاحتفال بافضل الكره السياحيه خلال العام
[موسيقى]